my name is Andrew grant and the
technical director for the MIT game lab
and some time lecturer I been playing
games pretty much all my life as my
family does and they get together and
then when computers started doing it too
that's what I do with computers I went
to the games industry in 1990 for work
for looking glass technologies and then
moved out to California to wear pretty
much interactive and actually all told
that didn't last terribly long I burned
out after about five or six years in the
games industry and it went to be a solo
programmer doing random contracts and
work-for-hire kind of like a gunslinger
from the Wild West for a while but no
matter what I do I keep getting dragged
back into games industry
I like making games that's what I want
to do
right now I'm playing a lot of things
I'm playing a lot of the cooperative
Lego games with my son he's four and
we're playing through Lego Batman and
that sort of thing and recently started
Lego Lord of the Rings which has been a
bit of a challenge room it's a much
darker Lego game oddly enough and so
he'll say things like his Boromir a bad
guy and I'm like well that's hard
let me explain to your four he's he's
confused it's call him a bad guy no he's
he's definitely a bad guy yeah but why
is he going with the hobbits oh right
he's kind of a good guy too
I don't know anyway it's a complicated
story for him for a four-year-old and
it's kind of fun
I'm working on a number of things right
now I'm working on a side project with
the Astronomy Department on some
software for them I'm working on a iOS
port of a game called Yomi and I'm also
working on a fractal Tana gram
independent game and with Rick also at
the lab I'm working on a massively
cooperative strategy game
this semester were trying a couple new
game engines we always try a couple new
game engines but I always like to get
let the students sink their teeth into a
couple of them and then come back and
tell us what they found out there's a
degree to which I can do that myself but
it really is more useful I think to get
some people with fresh eyes to come in
and try them out usually they come back
and tell us the old standbys the ones
they want to go with we usually end up
going with unity and Flixel as our
reliable ones but this year we're trying
out a new language hacks which also has
a flixel implementation and we're also
trying and getting called phaser which
is used by the education arcade and so
we really want to get our teeth into
that and see how we like it
I've always been Astrid in artificial
intelligence when I have a chance to
sort of sit down and play with stuff I
want to make my computer figure out how
to do things that it couldn't do before
it's a lot of fun
we're in a really interesting place I
think in games right now it used to be
the case that when I first started
playing that there would be two or three
cheating games a year and you could play
them and you waited very impatiently for
the next one to come out and now we're
in a place where you cannot play all the
interesting games in fact I can't even
play all the really interesting games
there's just too many of them but in
spite of that I still kind of want more
one of the neat things about games is
there's a whole bunch of different games
you can make and I feel like a lot of
times we get stuck on a couple types and
we don't necessarily need another
first-person shooter that's super
realistic modern combat there's some
good games there don't get me wrong but
we don't need five of them a year but
what we're really looking forward to is
seeing all the weird stuff the stuff
that no one expects the new crazy things
and the more games get made the more
crazy stuff gets made and I love that
stuff